this right here is the m1 max macbook  pro a laptop that is disrupting the  entire pc industry by not only offering  the best combination of performance  reliability and battery life than any  other laptop ever made but also by  making quick work of apple's most  expensive mac pro and even coming close  to some of the best desktop pcs in  certain workflows if you're going to be  going for that 14 inch macbook pro model  absolutely do not spend 200. to upgrade  to 32 cores because it's barely faster  and you lose out on a lot of battery  life we found that the 24 core 16 inch  model was almost as fast as the 32 core  14 inch model our recommendation is that  you should only get the full 32 cores if  you're getting the 16 inch macbook pro  and as far as whether you should buy 32  or 64 gigs of ram on your m1 max chip we  suggest 32 for 95 of the people out  there only get 64 gigs of ram if you  know you're gonna need it